-Our next guest is an Emmy-
nominated comedian and actress
you know from her
Netflix comedy specials
and shows like "Big Mouth,"
"Tuca & Bertie,"
"and Human Resources."
She stars in "Beef," which
premieres on Netflix April 6th.
Let's take a look.
-Come on. Talk to me.
-Okay, well, um,
you know, after the meeting,
I was sitting in the parking lot
thinking about how many meetings
and calls I've had to do
for the last two years.
Still, somehow
there's no offer coming.
And it just really
got to me, you know?
So then I started driving,
and then there was this guy --
-Hey, hey.
Before you spiral...
I'm gonna have you stop
right there.
Take a deep breath.
[ Inhales deeply ]
Pause.
You got to start focusing
on the positive. Okay?
You know, maybe
we should start doing
the gratitude journals again.
-Please welcome back
to the show Ali Wong,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Ali.
-Thanks for having me.
-I'm so thrilled to have you.
I know you were --
Early days, you were in New York
working on standup.
-I was -- I would do --
When I lived here, my God --
and hustling, I would do up
to sometimes 13 sets a night.
-That is insane to me.
Bouncing all around the city?
-Bouncing all around the city.
Sometimes to Brooklyn,
back to, like,
the Upper East Side,
to, like, Bed-Stuy,
to the Lower East Side.
And it was all for no money.
Sometimes three-minute sets.
-And, now, when you were
doing the same --
I'm assuming you're doing
the same three minutes
13 different times,
13 different audiences.
-Yeah.
-Would they just be
wildly different
as far as what worked where?
-Yeah, but I wasn't really
paying attention to that.
Like, I never paid attention
much to the audiences
because they were so crappy.
And a lot of the times
it was like,
you know, like,
random crazy people
jerking off into their eggs.
-Yeah.
-So it was like --
Who did not know
there was a comedy show
going on.
Oh, am I -- am I allowed
to say that about the eggs?
Oh, well. It's too late now.
-Well, you know what?
We are gonna get you
to ADR later --
"Putting salt on their..."
Real quick.
So I want to ask, though.
But you're getting no money,
and it doesn't seem like
you're getting helpful feedback.
So what were you
getting out of it?
-Well, it's more like
I have to pay attention
when I say it out loud
to the energy.
And, like, if I --
if I have confidence,
even if I bomb, like,
it's still funny.
That's really
valuable information.
You know, like if I still
feel like, okay,
even though this didn't
get much laughs,
like if I still feel
attached to it,
that tells me something,
you know?
-That -- I should also note
you make it look very easy,
your specials, and I think
it's a very nice thing for you
to admit how hard you have to
work to make it look so easy.
-Yeah, it was like it was --
And I still eat it a lot.
Like, when I go up at places,
people are always so excited
to see me,
and then I sort of talk
in this very, like, hushed --
Like, I don't put a lot
of performance into it.
And I talk in a sort of
monotone voice,
and then I can see
people's, like, face --
They're really excited,
and then it starts to fall,
and they're like,
"Oh, my God. She's lost it."
And then -- But, again,
it's really about the writing.
After a while,
it would get to the point
where no matter where I went,
those three minutes
would always still get laughs.
-That's such
a fascinating process.
-Yeah.
-I'm so happy
you put yourself through it.
So then, though, I didn't
realize you moved back to L.A.
You're doing all this work
on a comedy career,
and then you go to L.A.
-Well, I went to L.A.
actually to play
Christian Slater's assistant
in this sitcom,
and then I moved back
to New York for like a year
to be on this medical drama.
-Oh. So that was in New York.
-That was in New York.
I played
an agoraphobic radiologist
who had a love arc
with a plumber.
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
-You would be perfect for that.
-And then, like, that was
the first dramatic role
I ever had to do, kind of,
because I had --
It wasn't very funny,
but I was always
trying to be funny,
and the director was like,
"Stop trying to make
'occipital lobe' funny!
Just say what's going on
in the brain!"
And then I -- The show
also had Vanessa Redgrave.
Sure. A legend.
-A legend.
And then I remember overhearing
one of the directors talk about
directing Vanessa Redgrave,
and he was like,
"Oh, when she's on camera,
it's like directing
a Rolls-Royce."
And then I just walked away
because I knew
if someone asked him,
"What is it like to direct Ali?"
he would have said,
"It's like directing
a Toyota Yaris."
So I just left
because I was like,
"I don't want my feelings hurt.'
-I'm gonna use
the mention of cars
to segue very smoothly
to this wonderful
new show, "Beef."
This is about two people
who have a road-rage incident
and then become obsessed
with each other.
Excuse me.
Your costar, Steven Yeun.
He's wonderful.
-He's amazing.
-And this is a -- I mean,
there's very funny parts of it.
It's also very dramatic
at times.
-Yeah.
-And it's also very different.
We were talking backstage.
It seems very unique to me.
Did you enjoy it from the first
time you laid eyes on it?
-So when, like, the creator,
Lee Sung Jin,
came to me with Steven,
I just really wanted to work
with those guys.
That was, like, the biggest
priority. That was the biggest.
Like, it was like,
"You had me at hello."
Because I always wanted
to work with them.
And then after they told me
about the concept,
I was so excited,
and then when I read the pilot,
I just read it on my toilet
in one sitting,
and I had -- and my kids
kept on knocking on the door,
and I was like, "Hold on,
hold on, hold on, hold on!"
And I kept on, like,
scrolling through the iPad.
And then I had that, like,
signature ring
around my butt afterwards,
and I was like, "Oh, this
is a good project. Yeah."
-You called your agent and
you're like, "I got the ring."
-Yeah, yeah. "I got the ring."
-And you --
Did you first meet Steven
when he came
to see you do stand-up?
-Yeah. He was so sweet.
So, when my first stand-up
special, "Baby Cobra,"
came out...
-Fantastic.
-Oh, thanks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He sent a message to me on
Twitter about how great it was,
and he encouraged all of
his followers to watch it.
And then he came, and I think
he even paid money to --
for him
and a bunch of his friends
to come see me
at the Ace in downtown L.A.
-Did you know he was coming?
-I think I knew he was coming.
And then he came backstage
afterwards.
And then one of his friends
kept on taking pictures of me,
and I was like,
"Hey, man, what are you doing?!"
And Steven was like,
"This is my friend.
He's a portrait artist."
And that guy we ended up casting
as the husband that you see
in the clip.
-That was in the clip.
-Yeah.
-So there you go.
-He plays an artist
in the show, and then he's --
he's a real-life, incredible,
incredible painter, yeah.
-Well, that's fantastic.
It's really a great show.
And it's so lovely
to have you here.
Thanks for being back with us.
-Thanks so much for having me.
-Ali Wong, everybody. "Beef"
premieres on Netflix April 6th.
We'll be right back with music
from The Hold Steady.